if the protesters on january the 6th had
had their way joe biden and kamala
harris wouldn't have become president
and vice president a year on in their
eyes the blame for that remains firmly
with the former president
not that they once used his name
and here's the truth
the former president of the united
states of america
has created and spread a web of lies
about the 2020 election
he's done so because he values power
over principle
because he sees his own interest
as more important than his country's
interest than america's interest
and because his bruised ego
matters more to him than our democracy
or our constitution
he spoke in the very hall where 12
months ago protesters had trooped on
route to a deadly assault on democracy
[Applause]
inspired at the very least by the words
of the man desperate to hang on to the
presidency
and we fight
we fight like hell and if you don't
fight like hell you're not going to have
a country anymore
five died dozens were injured hundreds
have been prosecuted i did not seek this
fight
brought to this capital one year ago
today
but i will not shrink from it either
i will stand in this breach
i will defend this nation
not allow no one to place a dagger at
the throat of democracy
u.s capitol police officer brian siknik
u.s capitol police officer howard living
good on the floor of the house they
remembered in silence the officers who
died
this was a day of reflection but one
almost entirely of democrats that tells
you everything about the division in
america today
joe biden painted a vivid picture of the
horrors of what happened here a year ago
but as with many presidential addresses
to the american people these days it
raised the questions of who's listening
who hasn't already made up their minds
because this was a day as much as
anything about the elections that are to
come
trump still looms over american politics
he canceled a planned news conference
but issued a statement biden used my
name today to try to further divide
america he said this political theater
is all just a distraction for the fact
biden has completely and totally failed
the democrats want to own this day of
january the 6th so they can stoke fears
and divide america
the vice president compared january the
6th to pearl harbor and 9 11. it was an
assault on democracy she said this one
launched from within 12 months on it's
still an open wound with little sign of
healing